demain soir au parc des princes la
france devrait en battant chypre
confirmé sa victoire sur les pays bas et
gagner ainsi son billet pour la coupe du
monde en espagne
un match que les tricolores prennent
donc très au sérieux
même s'ils ont battu les chypriotes sets
à 0 il ya un peu plus d'un an un chiffre
l'un des meilleurs français le plus
régulier dans ses performances c'est le
nantais maxime bossis l'arrière gauche
bernard père vous le présente comme ses
camarades max bossis à préparer très
sérieusement ce match contre chypre
à 26 ans le nantais devenu l'une des
pièces maîtresses de l'équipe de france
est l'un des meilleurs arrières européen
pourtant l'homme est discret 'ft' peut
parler de lui en somme c'est l'anti
vedette sauf sur le terrain
particularité max bossis est le seul
joueur français à avoir joué tous les
matches de qualifications de la coupe du
monde mais il se méfie quand même et
chypre dernière info alors qu'on reste
village vigilant surtout surtout au
début en première mi-temps et
suffisamment de mieux terrain et
d'attaquants de valeur pour pouvoir
faire la différence et derrière france
surtout repenser à pas prendre de but
recréer quelque chose dans cette
rencontre
oui on craint on crée pas beaucoup
l'équipe de chypre mais
les certain que pour nous ce sera
surtout au niveau de notre équipe qui va
falloir lavaur et un beau jeu et se
créer beaucoup d'occasions pour pouvoir
marquer ils enclenchent je vais quand
même
et quand même important puisqu'il ya les
sky au bout et il pensait beaucoup à
l'espagne oui bien sûr ce serait dommage
de pas y penser à trois jours de la
qualification il faudrait quand même
qu'on arrive à aller là bas parce que je
pense ce serait la réussite d'une
génération
demain soir dans un parc des princes
archicomble à paroles devrait être aux
attaquants lacombe rocheteau 6 mais il
serait bien étonnant de ne pas voir
toute l'équipe de france tentait de
passer la défense chypriote et en
particulier un certain max bossis qui
ont cette occasion portera pour la 33e
fois le maillot tricolore